مالك بيتا القدس
نشكرك على جلوسك معنا
بشكل عام
عندما تكون بيتار القدس في
عناوين الأخبار الدولية ، فهي
مجموعة من المشجعين الموالين والمتطرفين الذين كانوا
حتى وقت قريب يفتخرون بحقيقة
أن بيتار لم يكن لديه أبدًا لاعب عربي
و  ومع ذلك ، فأنت تفكر
في جلب مستثمر من الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
فلماذا لا
تأتي هذه الفكرة منذ متى
كان هذا في العمل ، أعتقد أنه
منذ أسبوع تقريبًا
ربما تلقيت مكالمة هاتفية من
شخص
كبير  شركة استثمار في إسرائيل
من مالكها وأخبرني ، استمع
إلى أننا بحاجة إلى الاجتماع على
وجه السرعة ، حسنًا ، لقد التقينا في
اليوم التالي وأخبرني أنصت
أن هناك
عملاء من أبو
ظبي مهتمون بشراء
القدس البريطانية وأخبروهم استمعوا
للقدس  هي الأرض المقدسة إنها
العاصمة
إنها أقدس مكان في العالم ليس
فقط لليهود ولكن أيضًا للمسلمين
والمسيحيين ونقرأ
عن النادي الذي يحارب العنصرية
ونريد أن نكون على قدم المساواة  هذا هو
السبب في أنهم اقتربوا مني ،
لذلك لم يكن لدينا سوى عدد قليل من المكالمات الهاتفية
، وسرعان ما أعتقد بعد العطلة أنني
سأطير على الرغم من ذلك
ودعونا نأمل أن نتمكن من القيام بشيء ما
عندما
أحضرنا علي محمد إلى بيتاو ،
اشترينا  لاعب جيد ، لقد كلف
الكثير من المال ،
إنه لاعب جيد جدًا
واسمه علي محمد
وكان ذلك صعبًا على
جزء صغير من قاعدة المعجبين لدينا ،
إنه مسيحي ولكنه يحمل اسمًا مسلمًا نعم
والدته مسيحية والده
مسلم  لديه اسم مسلم
، لا يهم أي شيء يحمل
اسمًا مسلمًا
وكان ذلك تحديًا لنسبة قليلة
من قاعدة المعجبين لدينا
، حفل التوقيع رسميًا بين
إسرائيل والإمارات والبحرين.
لقد كنت تشاهد حتى ،
نعم كنت أشاهد. لقد كنت
متحمسًا للغاية بشأن هذا ،
وأعتقد أنه عندما تضع
البنية التحتية ،
فإن الأمر يستغرق وقتًا ولكن في النهاية
تستمتع بالفواكه
ولكن كرة القدم هي الناس وعندما
لدينا
شراكة aaa
بين الأمم بين شاب يهودي
من إسرائيل اسمه موشيه
ورجل عربي من الإمارات العربية المتحدة
اسم لا أعرف ماذا
ونحن نشجع نفس الفريق
ونحن نبني
هذا المجتمع ونقدم الخير نحن
كل ما نريده هو أن نرى الناس يلهون
من منظور كرة القدم وليس
السياسة وليس الدبلوماسية ،
ما الذي يمكن أن يجلبه هذا إلى Baytar ، أنت تعلم
أنني حالم
إذا حدث هذا ، اسمع لن أحضر
شريكًا
فقط لأقوله  لدينا شريك
من الإمارات إذا أحضرت شريكًا ،
فسيكون شريكًا مهمًا
يشترك في نفس الإيديولوجية
ولكن أيضًا لديه القدرة
المالية لنقل هذا النادي إلى مستوى مختلف
، والحلم بالطبع هو الفوز
بالبطولة واللعب فيه
دوري الأبطال ،
سيكون هذا هو الحلم أن يكون لدينا
فريق مهيمن
من الشرق الأوسط يتنافس
في أفضل مرحلة أوروبية رقم واحد
، حقبة جديدة للمنطقة وربما
حقبة جديدة
لبيتالي روسلين ماركي.  شكرا لك على وقتك شكرا لك